hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to destiny rebellion can I
get the nuclear rod and get out of here
oh my god you're even tinier than I
remember this is a bad place but it's
okay because we're gonna be here
together good job tiny box Tim you
really showed him what for a nuclear odd
good job tiny box Tim you found it I was
on you markiplier you're great thank you
I know now let's get out of here
well that doesn't sound good oh is this
the way out let's get out of your tiny
box Tim Oh No but tiny box Tim how will
I take you with me was that to anybody
sim okay good job tiny bugs Tim we're
gonna get this all sorted out
finish me do a fatality oh yeah oh god I
need though I have a present for you